bonjour mesdames bonjour messieurs je
suis venu vous présenter une histoire
mon histoire
en ma qualité de directeur du centre
pénitentiaire de lorient ploemeur et de
président de l'association osons les
défis mon histoire
si vous voulez la comprendre il faut
imaginer une pelote de laine une pelote
de laine qui va se dérouler sans cesse
comme mon destin thierry noël est qu il
dise le paladin mais deux coaches
synthétise mon histoire par l'art de
franchir les murs je pense que ces
provocateurs de parler comme ça d'un
directeur de prison
moi je préfère dire l'art de dérouler ma
vie de suivre mon destin m'a ressources
la ressource serait plutôt de favoriser
le talent de l'autre le talent des
autres d'ailleurs tedx m'a surnommé le
libérateur
encore une fois je trouve que ces
provocateurs de parler d'un directeur de
prison comme un libérateur
en même temps ils m'ont invité ils m'ont
invité
le 4 juillet jour d'indépendance aux
états unis beau symbole
un libérateur c'est quoi un sauveur un
émancipateur un défenseur libérateur je
l'étais très jeune par le football je
vous ai mis la flèche
c'est juste parce que je rentre plus
dans le short au football j'ai appris
des notions telles que l'effort
le collectif le respect des encadrants
au football j'ai été préparé pour être
libéraux libéraux c'est celui qui qui
couvre la défense qui coupe les
trajectoires des attaquants mais en même
temps surtout qui crée le surplus celui
qui va franchir les barrières ce qui est
amusant c'est que bien que j'étais
libéraux
j'étais un des meilleurs buteurs de
l'équipe au football très jeune j'ai
rencontré des joueurs qui sont devenus
des professionnels comme d'idées
cherchant par exemple patrie sauvage et
marcel desailly j'ai une blessure en
coupe de france qui m'a peut-être
empêché d'avoir ce parcours enfin
parcours professionnel lapsus parcours
de sportif en tout cas loin des yeux
loin des terrains loin du rêve c'était
la fin mais par contre c'était le début
d'une rencontre alexis lui qui est
devenu mon épouse je suis devenu papa 18
ans ah c'est vrai c'est rapide mais en
même temps je n'ai que 18 minutes pour
vous raconter mon histoire
alors que certains auraient pu être
complètement déstabilisé moi ça m'a
plutôt booster bélier ascendant bélier
ah oui ça arrache j'ai décidé d'abord
d'arrêter mes études l'année du bac
par contre obligatoirement faire le
service national et d'ailleurs j'ai bien
fait parce que c'est pendant mon service
national que j'ai compris que l'uniforme
était fait pour moi j'ai donc passé des
concours de police de gendarmerie et
l'administration pénitentiaire
des concours qui était possible sans le
bac mais surtout qui donnait la
possibilité de la promotion interne
étant papa je devais assurer la
paternité
j'ai pris le premier ça a été la
ministre à sion potentiel j'arrive à 20
ans à fleury mérogis c'était la première
fois que je mentais à paris on arrivait
pour vous
pareil
je connais je ne savais même pas qu'un
prisonnier est un détenu
je n'aime pas qu'une prison est un
établissement pénitentiaire
je ne savais pas qu'un gardien était un
surveillant et que d'autres appelez ça
un maton l'administration pénitentiaire
depuis 1987 j'ai connu onze
établissements des petites des moyennes
des grandes maisons d'arrêt des centres
de détention basé sur la route
socialisation des maisons centrales
basée sur la sécurité
l'administration centrale du ministère
en 28 ans j'ai exercé différentes
fonctions surveillant gradé formateurs
des personnels officiers officiers chef
d'établissement directeur directeur
d'établissement l'administration
pénitentiaire un métier mon métier mais
encore une fois comment vous le résumé
en 18 minutes
comment résumer quelque chose un
environnement un métier qui fait
beaucoup parler et vous voyez bien des
fois dans les reportages les différentes
perceptions qu'on peut avoir de ce
métier en ce qui me concerne le travail
la formation l'enseignement le soin la
culture le sport sont des outils
indispensables à la préparation à la
sortie à la prévention de la récidive
quand j'arrive à la maison centrale de
poissy
j'ai 24 ans les agents étaient très
expérimentés les détenus tête à tous et
partout avec des grosses grosses peines
ils voient ce jeune gradé effectivement
j'étais inquiet mois mais surtout eux
est inquiet de moi de mon inexpérience
le sport a été un levier à levier de
cohésion de management mais surtout un
levier d'insertion
le sport a permis grâce aux matchs qu'on
a pu faire avec les personnels contre
les détenus de
v les barrières de pouvoir discuter mais
c'est surtout en ma qualité de chef
d'établissement que j'ai pu aller
chercher le talent des autres
le talent de l'autre camp je suis nommé
pour la première fois la maison d'arrêt
de valenciennes en qualité de chef
d'établissement
je rends compte un docteur le docteur
thierry d'azun qui était fan comme moi
fan de sport notre premier projet était
de préparer des détenus au marathon de
new york symbole de liberté
bien sûr il faut s'inscrire longtemps la
vence la non réponse de ma hiérarchie a
fait que nous n'avons pas pu participer
à ce marathon
j'étais face au mur de l'administration
et au mur de l'atlantique en même temps
c'était quelques années après les
attentats de new york en et des détenus
avec des forte addiction
non je crois que ça pouvait pas le faire
mais moi ça me booste et ça m'a donné
envie de continuer ne pas s'arrêter
donc on est parti sur un 10 km et à 20
kilomètres au sein de l'établissement
on partait d'un terrain de sport jusqu'à
l'autre terrain de sport on faisait 20
boucles en passant par les chemins de
ronde des lieux où les détenus ne vont
jamais sauf pour s'évader les chemins de
ronde était sécurisé par des véhicules
des hommes cagoulés des fusils à pompe
je me rappelle juste avant le départ du
capitaine des pompiers le pipi de la
peur vous connaissez avant de partir sur
quelque chose qui veut faire ses besoins
à peine arrivé sur le mur il ya
quelqu'un qui descend avec le fusil à
pompe
je peux vous assurer c'est à couper
l'envié par contre malheureusement il a
gagné pour nous avec ces détenus
certains détenus nous avons continué
pour les accompagner sur le marathon de
la rochelle
bien sûr avec des addictions je me
souviens de karim qui a commencé pas
ralentir ses addictions
puis les stopper et perd 30 kilos en
trop entre
six mois vous imaginez les efforts d
imaginer les barrières karim s'était
fait un rêve celui de courir le marathon
en moins de quatre heures
il l'a fait nous l'avons fait avec lui
on est arrivé sur la ligne enfin la
ligne d'arrivée à la rochelle et vous
savez les speakers il disait le mot
maintenant vous savez qui je suis le
speaker dis bravo karim qui franchit la
ligne avec ses deux amis nous n'étions
pas à ses deux amis mais on était
peut-être beaucoup plus que ça pour lui
nous avions réussi avec lui d'atteindre
son rêve grâce à ces projets
j'ai pu aller aussi chercher le talon le
talent des personnels comme pascal qui
était un fan de photos j'ai pu le faire
travailler sur toutes les vidéos les
documentaires virginie vacca terrière
futur chef de cabinet qui a été sur
toute l'écriture des projets avec moi
david le moniteur de sport chaque fois
qu'il y avait un match de foot
les détenus se battaient entre eux ils
se prenaient la tête incapable de se
réguler un jour il est venu me voir et
m'a dit et si on faisait en sorte que
ces détenus deviennent arbitres de
football
nous avons créé la première session des
arbitres de football en prison ça s'est
développé
bien sûr après avec les districts grâce
à tous ces projets on a eu un prix au
sénat
c'était l'occasion de rencontrer pour
moi la fondation de la française des
jeux
alors pour vous pour certains la
fondation française des jeux la
française des jeux
c'est les gains le millionnaire les jeux
de grattage de tirage non pour moi
c'était la française des jeux
l'équipe professionnelle de cyclisme
d'ailleurs je remercie tedx d'invités
encore aujourd'hui le 4 juillet jour du
lancement du tour de france j'ai une
petite pensée pour ces cyclistes là je
demandais justement à ces personnes
comment il faisait pour s'entraîner
l'hiver
elle me disait l'hiver soit les
cyclistes habitent dans des pays chauds
ou dans des lieux chauds ou en tout cas
ils s'entraînent sur les home trainer et
entraîneurs vous prenez votre vélo vous
le mettez sur une machine de guerre
ou pédaler alors ça c'est l'association
as tu pas sûrs et sains vous avez mal
aux fesses mais quel plaisir après quand
vous retrouver le vélo moi j'ai compris
à ce moment là que je pourrais faire en
sorte que les détenus puissent
s'entraîner dans le gymnase
non pas pour des raisons de sécurité un
mais simplement pour des raisons de
ressources humaines dans ma tête
un autre projet pour des naissances la
ch'ti vente ou un projet d'insertion
médico sportif six détenus six étapes
1200 km
ces détenus travaillé toute la semaine
suivait un enseignement trois
enseignements par par semaine et en même
temps partait en entreprise une semaine
par mois en lien avec leur projet ces
détenus avaient tous une raison d'être
devant ce projet pour certains et même
pour beaucoup c'était pour une fois pas
quelqu'un quelqu'un de bien vis-à-vis
des autres pour une fois être dans le
positif dans la réussite
mohamed lui voulait devenir boulanger
emmanuel quantités quand il s'est
inscrit sur ce projet là son frère est
décédé
voyez on a connu tout c'est toutes ces
valeurs on nous devions aller jusqu'au
bout marc madiot le directeur sportif
quand je lui ai présenté ce projet m'a
dit gens veulent imaginer faire en sorte
que des détenus en six mois qui ne sont
même pas des sportifs même pas des
cyclistes puissent faire ton projet et
finir par le mont ventoux
personne ne croyait en nous et pourtant
nous avons nous avons réussi même moi
qui ai un mois avant de partir étaient
blessés ne motorex 5o de pia ses
clavicules en l'air par rapport à un
sprint mal géré et on va dire
c'est comme ça l'art de franchir les
murs l'art de franchir les montagnes
quand nous sommes arrivés là haut sur le
mont ventoux que j'ai vu tout le monde
se congratule et s'embrasser c'était
vraiment émouvant et là je me suis dit
ok six détenus
il ya soixante mille en france alors le
matin je réfléchis beaucoup quand je
m'en reste c'est là que j'ai des idées
et le soir très tard j'ai encore des
idées et donc un soir à 23h m'est venue
l'idée de d un cpu les murs qu'il faut
franchir ces puits la montagne c'est les
régions administratives l'administration
pénitentiaire est découpé en neuf
régions nous avons 192 établissements
pour moi c'était cohérent il suffisait
de créer le tour de france cycliste
pénitentiaire
donc j'ai pris ma feuille et j'ai
commencé à créer ce projet-là 12 étapes
de mise de 1400 km ce projet a permis de
rouler avec 200 détenus et 300
personnels ce projet c'est plus les
montagnes on avait déplacé c'est plus la
région administrative c'est 45 pays qui
ont médiatisé ce projet après tant
d'émotions dans d'événements dans deux
choses partager avec les autres
j'ai eu un moment de nous la crise de
quarantaine je ne sais pas crise
existentielle soit sûrement pas mais
simplement mon destin ou al hiti l'aller
en 2010 j'ai 40
trois ans ça vous laisse calculer je
deviens papy l'art de franchir les murs
mais aussi l'art de franchir les
événements familiaux
je vous ai dit que j'étais devenu papa
18 ans et anne était donc pas mon
premier petit garçon je suis devenu pape
sy a 37 ans et anne était donc le 5e et
dans quelques jours je serai papy d'un
sixième avec ethan ça a été pour moi la
révolution créé une association une
association qu'elle est portée sur les
fondations et les fondations
elle ne pouvait pas être justement créé
une fondation j'avais pas de moyens
financiers
donc ça a été la révélation créé une
association une association qui
s'appelle ozon les défis sa porte bien
son terme
osant les défis l'insertion l'éducation
la solidarité la culture par le sport
les premiers projets de cette
association ne pouvait être que humains
créateurs mais surtout impossible
c'est ma marque de fabrique quand même
nous sommes partis sur des projets bien
sûr autour du tour de france autour de
l'handicap en 2013
nous avons réédité la 100ème book du
tour de france six étapes les étapes
font 500 kilomètres ont pédalé 27 eur on
se repose et 3h et en repartent et 27
heures ou les jours nuit pendant six
jours comme ça un truc de fou et
pourtant ces treize cyclistes j'ai été
les chercher c'est mon peut-on des
copains que j'avais à droite et à gauche
quand vous voyez que bernard de
que sur une jambe
samuel qui luttait contre sa maladie
louis qui est atteint de la tuberculose
qui étaient sous traitement qui
vomissent et tous les matins et pourtant
nous l'avons fait ce projet là ces
projets là nous venons encore 2
continuez j'ai encore les stigmates un
bracelet du tour de france ce week-end
nous venons de faire 400 km avec 500
cyclistes
ce qui m'intéresse c'est de ne rien
faire pour moi c'est de faire avec les
autres quelque chose pour d'autres et
c'est ça qui m'intéresse
nous avons souhaité partager nos valeurs
nos défis avec deux associations
la première association les enfants de
la lune ses enfants comme vous le voyez
sont atteints d'une maladie rare bening
ils sont obligés de se protéger contre
les rayons du soleil
s'il ne se protège pas on va dire vers
l'âge de 10 ans il risque de décéder
ces enfants doivent vivre comme nous ne
doivent pas rester dans leur maison
protégée
ils doivent aller vers la scolarité est
justement les masques permettent à ces
enfants de pouvoir sortir mais les
masques qu'ils avaient jusqu'à présent
n'avaient pas de ventilateur
depuis 2013 avec qui nous travaillons
sur pour cette association nous avons
déjà d'abord communiquer sur cette
association est en même temps récolter
des dons déjà dix mille euros de dons ce
premier ventilateur a déjà été une
grande avancée
certains masques aux deux ventilateurs
ce qui permet à ces enfants d'avoir même
une activité sportive la deuxième
association que nous avons aidé ces dons
d'organes et de tissus
bien sûr communiqué est ce que vous
savez que l'on peut donner certains de
nos organes jusqu'à 90 ans
est ce que vous savez qu'aujourd'hui 40%
des personnes qui vont donner leurs
organes ne verront pas leur volonté
exaucée puisqu'il n'en avait pas parlé
avec leurs familles franchir les tabous
franchir les lignes
voilà ce que nous devons faire ce
week-end j'ai roulé avec un cycliste qui
est en attente d'une greffe d'un rein
ce cycliste a accompli un exploit mais
pour moi l'exploit est surtout été le
lendemain son épouse qui est professeur
d'école
le lendemain au lieu de faire un rond
tour de son expérience avec ses élèves
sur le don d'organes elle est venue
parler des enfants de la lune
voilà moi c'est ça que j'attends qu'on
vienne pas parler de soi mais convient
de parler des autres
notre association
osant les défis voyez je porte les
couleurs
oui la montagne bien sûr vous avez
compris que rien ne m'arrête un petit
bonhomme qui va gravir ces maillots
notre site
osant les défis no logo tout ça a été
créé par des personnes qui ne
connaissaient pas leur talent
si vous mon histoire mon destin nous
intéresse moi c'est surtout le vôtre
m'intéresse alors peut-être que notre
chemin se croisera et pour cela je vous
donne la pelote de laine
merci